des incertitudes n'ont jamais été aussi
importantes c'est la raison pour
laquelle je voudrais vous rendre hommage
voici les mots avec lesquels jean castex
le premier ministre a commencé son
discours un discours devant des chefs
d'entreprise réunis pour deux jours à
l'hippodrome de longchamp dans le cadre
des rencontres avec le medef un premier
ministre se voulait rassurant auprès de
ces entreprises après cette première
vague je pourrais la virus et surtout ce
confinement qui a beaucoup pesé dans les
comptes et surtout des caisses des
différentes entreprises surtout celles
de l'état le gouvernement a promis
d'être auprès de ces entreprises en
bloquant débloquant bien sûr des prêts
et garanties des fonds de solidarité
mais aussi un plan de relance d'un
montant de près de 100 milliards d'euros
le premier ministre est revenu sur ce
montant en déclarant que c'était
historique un des plus importants de
l'union européenne il a déclaré que tout
était mis en oeuvre pour éviter un
deuxième confinement général je vous
propose d'écouter le premier ministre je
veux que vous sachiez le pays tout
entier sache que nous préparant toutes
les hypothèses y compris celle où notre
système de santé viendrait à nouveau
être fortement sollicité mais je le dis
ici
calmement mais fermement nous sommes
prêts notre objectif premier c'est de
tout mettre en oeuvre pour éviter le
recours un confinement général donc nous
ne connaissons que trop le coup et les
conséquences vous l'aurez compris
objectifs du gouvernement éviter à
nouveau leur confinement des aides qui
seront bien sûr clarifier à partir du
1er septembre prochain objectif du
gouvernement se tenir prêts des
entreprises mais aussi des salariés
c'était la déclaration qu'a voulu
transmettre et surtout le message qu'a
voulu transmettre le premier ministre
devant ce parterre de chefs d'entreprise
réunis à l'hippodrome de longchamp dans
le cadre des rencontres du medef pour
deux jours de discussions et de débats
une rencontre rebaptisé à l'occasion la
renaissance des entreprises françaises
tout un symbole
en pleine crise du coronavirus